Most addicts don't want to die.
They injected themselves with no one else around.
They didn't want to die, and they shouldn't die.
Fatal overdoses from opioids in the United States have increased about 250% since 2007.
Opioids now make up over two-thirds of all overdose deaths.
The problem is particularly acute in a handful of states, including Pennsylvania,
which has the third highest overdose death rate in the country.
In the city of Philadelphia overdose deaths are concentrated in the neighborhood of Kensington,
which is the epicenter of the city's opioid crisis.
But advocates here are now planning to open a so-called "supervised injection site,"
targeted not just at helping addicts break their addiction,
but at keeping them alive as they continue to use.
And the federal government has sued to stop them from opening.
Safe injection sites are a way of making better use of a drug called Naloxone,
often known by the brand name Narcan.
Which is remarkably effective at stopping overdoses as they're occurring.
Opioid molecules bind to the receptors that control respiration.
During an overdose breathing can slow or stop entirely.
This can lead to severe brain damage or asphyxiation and death.
Narcan binds to the opioid receptors in the brain displacing any present opioid molecules.
It can rapidly reverse the effects of an overdose in as little as two minutes.
Though it has no side effects, Narcan is hard to come by.
It's not available over-the-counter,
and in some states doctors aren't allowed to prescribe it to someone who doesn't intend on using it themselves.
Philly's supervised injection site would be a place where addicts can use drugs
in the presence of medical professionals ready to administer narcan to abort an overdose.
The facility will also provide clean needles and a sanitary environment.
The project is called safe house, and it's rumored that organizers are planning to locate it
in this nondescript warehouse on a side street in Kensington that's littered with needles.
Safehouse would be the first supervised injection site in the United States operating out in the open.
But in 2014 a social service agency opened a covert facility in an undisclosed urban neighborhood in the US.
According to a 2017 study in the American Journal of Preventive Medicine,
over two years 2,574 injections were performed at the site.
90% of which would have otherwise occurred in a public restroom, street, park, or parking lot
according to participants.
Two overdoses were treated immediately with Narcan.
There are over 120 supervised injection sites across the globe.
Safehouse is modeled after Insite, a supervised injection site in Vancouver, Canada.
Founded in 2003, Insite has played a key role in studies of the efficacy of harm reduction techniques
offered by supervised injection sites.
It is not lawful to facilitate the illegal use of drugs.
Projects like Safehouse however are in violation of the so called "crack house" statute,
which was part of the federal Anti-Drug Abuse Act of 1986.
We don't supply anybody with drugs. We don't touch drugs. None of our personnel do.
Ed Rendell, who’s both a former governor of Pennsylvania and a former Mayor of Philly,
sits on the board of the nonprofit that's behind Safehouse,
and he's been instrumental in building support for the project.
A lot of those people are in their twenties.
If they straighten out and get treatment and get off the addiciton,
they could gone on to do wonderful things for themselves, for their families, for us as a society.
According to the law, it's illegal to maintain any property for the purpose of manufacturing, distributing,
or using any controlled substance.
Violators can be sentenced up to 20 years in prison and face a fine of up to half a million dollars.
It never really was meant to be illegal, the Senators and Congressmen who developed the crack house statute
never in a million years thought about volunteer medical personnel
standing by while someone injected themselves ready to reverse the effects of the overdose.
Do you think they thought for a minute that that activity should be criminal? Of course not.
In early 2019 the Department of Justice preemptively sued Safehouse
and its executive director, Jeanette Bowles,
to make it easier to begin making arrests if the project moves forward.
We're asking the federal government to use their prosecutorial discretion and not make an arrest
for a violation of a statute that never meant to cover this type of activity.
We'll go ahead with it, and maybe we'll end up in federal prison.
It's not the first time Rendell has squared off with authorities for policies intended to help addicts.
In 1992, when he was Mayor of Philly, a group of activists opened a needle exchange
called Prevention Point, to combat the AIDS epidemic.
When Rendell signed an order allowing it to proceed he received a call from the state health commissioner
who said he would be arresting anyone involved with the program.
I said, Mr. Secretary come to 212 City Hall and arrest me first.
Prevention point went on to be a great success.
Our model is used in 30 other American cities,
and the Congress went ahead and legalized the operation of prevention.
Rendell see Safehouse as a continuation of that same mission.
Before they're allowed to inject it in the presence of medical personnel,
before they're allowed to get a shower, et cetera,
they have to listen to a social worker and talk to them about treatment options.
Safehouse countersued, citing moral and religious imperatives for the opening of the facility.
The case is still pending, but Rendell and the other board members are dead set on opening Safehouse
regardless of the outcome.
I don't think that government should be wasting resources,
arresting doctors and nurses who are volunteering their time.
I don't think they should do that.
All we want to do is save some,
some young people from, from...
...from dying needlessly.
That's all we want to do.